parce qu'elle a refusé de porter le
voile l'entretien de la journaliste
Christiane Amman pour avec le président
iranien et Brahim raïti a été annulé
après 40 minutes d'attente un conseiller
du président est venu voir la chef de
l'antenne internationale de CNN pour lui
dire que Brahima ici suggéré qu'elle
porte un voile la journaliste né en
Grande-Bretagne d'un père iranien
raconte j'ai poliment refusé nous sommes
à New York où il n'existe aucune loi ou
tradition concernant le port du foulard
j'ai fait remarquer qu'aucun président
iranien précédent de l'avait exigé
lorsque je l'avais interviewé en dehors
de l'Iran et elle conclut nous avons
laissé tomber l'interview n'a pas eu
lieu alors que les manifestations se
poursuivent en Iran et que des personnes
sont tuées cela aurait été important de
parler avec le président racisme en Iran
les manifestations se poursuivent après
le décès de Massa Amini 22 ans elle
avait été arrêtée par la police des
mœurs pour port de vêtements
inappropriés au moins 31 personnes ont
été tuées depuis le début de la
mobilisation
[Musique]